you imagine if anything could get
anything pregnant yeah a new combination
was born turtle people - that's what's
next toy people some - [ __ ] - koi yeah
busted into that koi mom knocked that
coin imagine you're out there throwing
bread on your koi pond okay it has legs
what the [ __ ] man so many [ __ ] people
see you at the pet store shopping and
they're like whoa this guy's shady is
imagine if Ari [ __ ] it and it came out
and we knew it because that Ari's knows
yeah so it's like Ari's nose on a koi
fish with legs and it comes out Ari
would know your business but if you had
to make love to an animal would it be if
you think you had to go in there
something I could brag about yeah what
if you had gay sex with an animal which
animal would it be that's not gay -
[ __ ] animal bro it's not I don't
think that applies dude you're [ __ ]
an animal that's Seymour both if it's a
like a male gorilla I think it's both
dude okay and bestiality
bro you would never buy a beer again you
put you want to break the internet you
put a [ __ ] video and me sneaking up
on a cheetah
yeah and [ __ ] it well gavel rapping a
noose around its neck and you're banging
it while it's clawing on yeah no I'm
talking about putting on some just Eddie
Levert or some gerald levert and playing
some sweet music and just looking like
how you plan on holding it in place
while it's all happening I think if
you're good enough and gentle enough
it'll stay I love to look at the world
through your eyes whatever medication
we're on we got to change it we gotta
fix this
bro you should meet yourself then bro
you are
extraterrestrial
[Laughter]